لحظات مليئه بالعاطفه ضجت بها مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي لفتاه تحاول ان تساعد
والدها المصاب بالزهايمر على استرجاع
ذكرياته الضائعه الفتاه التي كانت تستعد
لزفافها منحت والدها ادوات الرسم وهو
النشاط الذي كانا يمارسانه سويا في
طفولتها ليسترجع لحظاته معها من خلال
الرسم بمشاهد
ون
[موسيقى]
لحظات فعلا مؤثره موقف جميل كان من البنت
حتى يتذكرها والدها
وعلى فكره يعني على الرغم من انه مثلا
الالزايمر هو بيقدر يسرق اجمل ذكريات اللي
بعيشها الاحبه الا انه بيقولوا دائما انه
ممكن مقاومه هاي الامور وممكن بالتفكير
يعني اعاده تكرار الامور وحتى كمان في بعض
الادويه ممكنه الاشخاص الذين يملكون مصابا
في عائلتهم بهذا المرض القاسم يتحدث عن
الزهايمر دورهم اساسي كما قلتي بالتذكير
فالنحيا النفسيه مهمه جدا في التقليل من
اثر الزهايمر وكمان في علماء يقولون بانه
مبادره ابحاث الزايمر انه احد اهم الطرق
لهذا العلاج وتقليل حتى من الاثار انه
دائما يشوف المصاب بالسايمر صور اشخاص
اللي بيعرفهم باستمرار وهيك بالتالي بيسهل
عليه انه يرجع يتذكرهم على امل كمان من
الناحيه العلميه الطبي يوصي ايضا ان يكون
هناك فحص دائم لوظائف المريض الحيويه
المصاب بالزهايمر للسيما السمع
اذا ما لوحظ عسوف المريض عن المشاركه في
الاحاديث مع العائله والنقاشات رغم الكثير
من المحاولات لتقديم دواء يعالج الزهايمر
يناديدا في محاولات طبيه كثيره للخروج
بدواء يعني للاسف هو ما زال تاثيره قوي
جدا امام كل هذه الادويه والمحاولات
العلميه والطبيه ويبقى ما يقدم ضمن خانه
ادويه اداره الاعراض المرضيه يعني هذا
بالمسمى العلمي لهذا الموضوع هو مرض يعني
قاسي على العائله تحديدا عندها مصابر